when you went to the Oscars this time
they did not want you to be in character
right that's right the way I heard it is
you were like [ __ ] you my wife's gonna
hide the outfit yeah and I am going to
do whatever the hell I want I was
nervous I tell you why because obviously
the ratio issue was a big issue at the
Oscars be the issue yeah the issue and I
decide you know what I'm gonna do
allergy and the problem is I'm doing a
character who thinks he's black yeah but
they're gonna introduce me as Sacha
Baron Cohen and my first line is going
to be I know what you was all thinking
you know the Academy has brought on yet
another token black presenter I love
that line but I'm thinking all right if
you know a lychee you're going to
realize that's funny if you don't know
who Ali G is in other words 99% of the
people out there you're going to think
that satyr Aaron Cohen is pretending to
be black right I told two people I told
one English guy and the other guy said
don't tell anyone you know I'm I'm gonna
do energy right and it goes up really I
go this is my first line tell what you
think because do not do that man that's
actually racist racialist
rachel is there and then on the way in I
saw Dave Chappelle uh-huh I got Dave I
need you for 35 seconds please is that
right Dave
I'm going on and doing Ali G this is my
first line tell me whether I'm going to
get killed
he's like it's great get out then do it
and so we went backstage and then me and
my wife disappear into this toilet for
40 minutes because she has to put on the
beard la is the only place where you can
disappear into the bathroom with another
woman 45 minutes and nobody else any
questions right did you about a dragger
but aren't they looking for you they're
looking for me and like I've got my
publicist telling them that I've got
terrible diarrhea so when you walk out
in your Ali G outfit so I didn't so I
didn't so basically I walk out in the
beard I'm covering my hand over my beard
and I was here they're all looking at
the stage I walk to the edge of the
stage and then Olivia wads there I said
I live here I'm doing Ali G I put the
cap on I put the glass on I said tuck in
my hair I didn't know how she was gonna
react and she was great she talks in my
hair puts in the thing
which is you want I go yeah so that's it
I knew I had five seconds to tell her
and get it done
doesn't Olivia I'm doing allergy tuck in
my hair